abbiamo i paraocchi tutti ma molti di
noi non se ne accorgono E questo forse
accade perché ce li siamo messi da soli
ma di cosa sto parlando sto parlando di
questi
magnifici paraocchi moderni oggetti
divenuti onnipresenti
utilissimi indispensabili Ma come ogni
cosa presente su questa Terra ha dei
pregi e dei difetti e i difetti più
evidenti sono già noti a molti per cui
non voglio annoiare nessuno questa sera
ma vorrei in questa sede focalizzarmi
solo su quello che è il tema qui oggi la
luce in particolare nelle varie
declinazioni del concetto di luce che si
interseca con quello che io non so come
definire Se mio ambito di ricerca
interesse hobby
passione Mania Non lo so quello che so è
che io sono Federico manutti e che
scopro le tracce minori che la grande
storia lasciato lungo le nostre strade e
le racconto principalmente sui social
luce prima declinazione la luce proibita
nelle nostre città resistono alcune
lettere dell'alfabeto dipinte sui muri e
se hanno un significato forse oscuro La
maggior parte dei cittadini perché ci
passiamo davanti non le Notiamo molti di
noi non si chiedono il significato
iniziamo con quelle più frequenti
la
idrante
che vedo solo lì ma non lì è lì adesso
Ecco è apparsa i nera su fondo bianco
sta per idrante poi abbiamo una più rara
B bocca di idrante
P Pozzo con una freccia indicare dov'è
ubicato questo pozzo e ancora vi
ventilazione altra freccia poi arriviamo
ad una serie di Us
uscite sicura uscite di sicurezza in
varie forme
in varie declinazioni arriviamo
ad un'altra lettera molto importante
Forse è la più importante tra quelle che
vi spiegherò stasera la r
RC
Ecco svelato l'arcano rifugio
indica
dei rifugi e quindi già in questo
frangente riusciamo a capire qual è il
significato di questo alfabeto
dimenticato siamo negli ultimi anni
della Seconda Guerra Mondiale La nostra
penisola è pesantemente bombardata e per
cercare di proteggere la popolazione da
questo grave pericolo viene istituita
questa che la segnaletica di sicurezza a
muro
che indica dove la popolazione può
proteggersi
avevano un duplice scopo quello di
indicare appunto i cittadini dove fosse
il rifugio più vicino
pensiamo anche a chi nel momento
dell'attacco si trovava distante dalla
dimora abituale
e Servivano anche i soccorritori per
liberare le vie di fuga in caso di
crollo degli edifici
liberare le bocche di ventilazione per
non far morire le persone eventualmente
ancora all'interno del bunker e ancora
indicare le adduzioni d'acqua per
spegnere i frequenti incendi che
accadevano durante i bombardamenti
incendi che avevano facile vita negli
edifici che facevano Largo uso di legno
pensiamo ai solai ai tetti
questi rifugi potevano essere dei veri e
propri bunker ma più spesso erano dei
semplici scantinati che erano stati
adibiti a questo scopo e riportavano
anche la capienza nella slide precedente
c'è un esempio di Vicenza
286 P Cioè persone Quella è la capienza
massima questo che vediamo invece è un
esempio Milanese 11 persone e sullo
sfondo 12 persone Dobbiamo immaginare la
fretta e l'ansia con cui avvenivano gli
ingressi in questi spazi e in quegli
anni l'illuminazione pubblica viene
limitata al minimo indispensabile per
cercare di dare meno informazioni
possibili al nemico
luce proibita i cittadini sono costretti
ad attendere ore nei rifugi spesso al
buio luce negata provando quella che per
testimonianze dirette che ho raccolto
personalmente mi è stata descritta come
la paura più grande provata nella loro
vita quindi persone terrorizzate che
stavano al buio
passavano anche molte ore pregando luce
della speranza e queste tracce di
importanza vitale per queste persone
sono state per lo più dimenticate dopo
la guerra rimaste lì a sbiadire sui muri
finché qualcuno libero per qualche
momento Dai parrocchi di cui sopra non
ci posa sopra lo sguardo incuriosito e
se ne interessa luce della conoscenza
luce seconda declinazione propaganda E
durante le mie ricerche
ho trovato lui
nel 1925 sotto il regime fascista viene
fondato l'istituto luce in realtà nasce
un anno prima come
l'unione cinematografica educativa idea
poi messa completamente al servizio
della propaganda che vede nella settima
Arte del cinema
una potenza di penetrazione e di
stagione che nessun altro elemento può
avere Ma alla propaganda non bastava
bisognava essere presenti ovunque
attraverso un mezzo comunicativo che
ancora oggi a distanza di quasi 100 anni
continua a trovare lungo le nostre
strade i Motti del ventennio sui muri
emblema del Fascismo sono per i pochi
che non lo sapessero questo genere di
frasi per lo più dipinte a caratteri
cubitali che portavano ovunque il
pensiero fascista ribadendo ad ogni
passaggio che il cittadino compiva il
suo credo erano più frequenti nei borghi
rurali che in città l'origine di questi
Motti era diversa la maggior parte erano
solitamente
estratti dai discorsi pubblici di
Mussolini
altre volte erano semplicemente attinti
alla saggezza popolare mi viene in mente
la terra non tradisce mai o cose del
genere o anche prese in prestito un
esempio celebre è il famoso molti nemici
molto onore che in realtà è attribuito
al Faraone Ramses
esistevano apposite liste di ramate dai
ministeri Anzi dal ministro dal
ministero della propaganda che
attraverso circolari faceva arrivare in
tutta la penisola un elenco con
l'indicazione dei luoghi adatti ad ogni
tipo di frase
e anche l'indicazione delle tecniche di
realizzazione che prevedevano delle
vernici molto durature
tant'è che
resistivano molto bene alle intemperie
ed anche alle pitture censorie
che sono state applicate
man mano che la Guerra di Liberazione
avanzava
le frasi del ventennio scandiscono anche
le fasi del ventennio La Motta iniziali
di ricerca del consenso tra gli
scontenti della Prima Guerra Mondiale si
fa spesso riferimento alla vittoria
mutilata quindi questa vittoria a metà
che molti vedevano nella Guerra Mondiale
non tutte le promesse erano state
mantenute
a detta di alcuno avevano erano frasi
anche dal significato molto generico
anche banali se vogliamo con cui avere
facile Largo consenso noi diciamo prima
i diritti poi doveri
al contrario noi diciamo prima doveri
poi diritti bisogna essere forti chi si
ferma e perduto bisogna usare fino ad
arrivare al tentativo di formazione del
fascista perfetto il celeberrimo creder
obbedire combattere oppure il famoso
libro e Moschetto fascista perfetto la
patria va servita eccetera eccetera
le critiche alle sanzioni internazionali
dopo la conquista dell'Etiopia
fino ad arrivare a dei motti di guerra
che poi si riducono una volta
invischiati nel conflitto
in semplici e sempre meno convinti
vincere
Ecco un esempio il Duce con sopra
vincere ed un'ultima slide vincere
scritta in modo non molto convinto
guerra assenza di luce
luce terza declinazione
lampade ora torniamo indietro di più di
100 anni con queste antiche
tabelle pubblicitarie di inizio
Novecento di un prodotto nuovo
rivoluzionario terza declinazione del
concetto guida di questa serata forse
quello più banalmente associabile fare
luce luce elettrica Ecco una delle
novità del Novecento è appunto la luce
elettrica c'è bisogno di lampade
elettriche c'è bisogno di vendere Ed
ecco che queste tabelle molto colorate
venivano esposte né gli esercizi
commerciali
e si rivolgevano
ai cittadini per vendere un nuovo
prodotto cittadini che si apprestavano a
diventare consumatori oggi lo diamo per
scontato ma la luce elettrica è stata
una grande rivoluzione andando a
sostituire la scarna illuminazione a gas
o
allume di candela ha cambiato il modo di
vivere le città che per gli standard di
oggi erano praticamente al buio
senza dubbio un vantaggio per la
vivibilità per la sicurezza eccetera ma
ogni cosa ha un prezzo ed il prezzo da
pagare è che l'inquinamento luminoso da
queste nuove fonti luminose
ha necessariamente
nascosto
la luce delle stelle e la luce della
luna quindi la luce persa luce quarta
declinazione
se io dico 365 all'alba
ho già l'attenzione di chi come me è
maschio e ha passato i 40 anni perché
365 perché Alba perché 365 sono i giorni
dell'anno di Leva che fino agli anni 90
i maschi italiani erano obbligati
a
fare e questo periodo veniva visto da
molti come un periodo buio anche se poi
la maggior parte delle persone ha un
buon ricordo del servizio di leva Ma
veniva anche goliardicamente visto come
un periodo buio alla fine della quale
c'era la luce c'era l'alba
la luce alla fine del tunnel in sostanza
e quindi 1918 nati a rombo del Cannone
Che cosa sono sono dei
Graffiti goliardici che trova in
quantità piuttosto importante ancora
oggi lungo le nostre strade
Questo è un esempio che mi piace molto
in friulano ciapa la vita dall'alpin gli
holdi con Morbin letteralmente prendere
la vita come fall Alpino godere con Brio
con l'immancabile mulo e fiasco di vino
e poi Un tripudio di Viva la classe 1928
viveva 1932 perché i ragazzi partivano e
prestavano servizio militare in base
agli scaglioni cioè il periodo di
nascita e quindi stencil viva 1948 con
un aereo disegnata stencil viva 1950 un
viva 1930 con un fiasco di vino delle
penne che ricordano gli alpini
un esempio
un esempio del periodo di guerra il
vincere di cui prima torna in questo
questo graffito goliardico
immaginiamo sia stato fatto in periodo
di guerra perché i nati nel 22 avevano
18 anni nel 40/20 anni nel 42
arriviamo a un di cui non si passa viva
1913 con un Alpino che brandisce il suo
fucile in Cina in cima ad una montagna
e vi voglio lasciare con un graffito a
cui sono molto legato questo
sulla destra si può vedere ritratto di
lato un ragazzo alpino con il suo
caratteristico cappello che inclina la
testa ed è nell'atto di baciare la sua
amata prima di un lungo Addio bene Ci
sono affezionato perché era davanti a
casa mia
ma solo dopo che mi sono tolto i
paraocchi l'ho visto e vi invito a farlo
Grazie
[Applauso]